اعلن عدد من الدول العربيه المنضويه تحت
مظله منظمه اوبك الى جانب روسيا عن تخفيض
طوعيا في انتاجها النفطي اعتبارا من شهر
مايو ايار القادم وحتى نهايه العام الجاري
في خطوه احترازيه تهدف الى دعم استقرار
اسواق البترول وقال مسؤول بوزاره الطاقه
السعوديه ان المملكه تنفذ تخفيضا طوعيا في
انتاجها بمقدار 500 الف برميل يوميا بينما
اعلنت وزاره النفط العراقيه ان العراق
سيخفض انتاجه من النفط بمقدار
21 الف برميل يوميا اما وزير النفط
الاماراتي فاعلن ان بلاده ستخفض انتاج
النفط طوعا
144 الف برميل يوميا اما الكويت فستخفض
انتاجها النفطي طبيعيه بمئه وثمانيه
وعشرين الف برميل يوميا حسب وزير النفط
الكويتي وقالت و زاره الطاقه الجزائريه
انها ستخفض انتاجها النفطي بمقدار ثمانيه
واربعين الف برميل يوميا من جهه اخرى اعلن
نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسي ان روسيا ستخفض
طوعيا انتاجها النفطي 500 الف برميل يوميا
اعتبارا من مايو ايار القادم وحتى نهايته
العام الحالي
معنا من لندن لهذا اسماعيل الصحفي المختص
بشؤون الطاقه مرحبا بك نهاد اسماعيل في اي
سياق يمكن فهم الدوافع من وراء هذه الخطوه
نعم شكرا على الاستضافه وتحياتي لكم في
الجزيره في الواقع هناك مخاوف في صفوف
اوبك ان الاسعار قد
تشهد مزيدا من الهبوط هبطت في حوافي 20
مارس لخام غرب الى 65 دولار للبرميل
والخام برنت حوالي 70 دولار البرميل هذا
الانخفاض الكبير هو اعمق انخفاض منذ سنه
وثلاث شهور يعني 15 شهر ادنى مستوى لهذه
الاسعار والمخاوف الابيساب الازمه الماليه
ازمه البنوك والمصارف والمخاوف والانتشار
العدوى واي ازمات اضافيه قد تاتي في
المستقبل قد تؤدي الى انهيار الاسعار لذلك
خطوه احترازيه وخطوه استباقيه الاجتماع
غدا
للجنه المراقبه الوزاريه لانه
القرار سيكون الاستمرار في الاتفاق الذي
الذي تم في خمسه اكتوبر 2022
لتخفيضه 2 مليون برميل يوميا حتى نهايه
هذا العام
بالاضافه الى التخفيضات الجديده التي اعلن
عنها اليوم هذه التخفيضات طبعا الاعلان
عنها لوحده فقط
سيعزز الاسعار وسيرفع الاسعار وسنرى ذلك
في عند افتتاح الاسواق غدا الاسعار الجمعه
تعافت الى مستويات افضل يعني وصل خام برنت
حوالي 79 دولار وكخاب غرب تكساس الوسيط
الى 75 دولار لذلك هناك تقلبات واضطرابات
في الاسواق سببها
الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه الان دعنا نسال
عن المفاعيل السياسيه لهذا القرار لان
تخفيضات سابقه كانت يعني
كانت ضد اراده الولايات المتحده
واغضبت الولايات المتحده كيف يمكن ان
تتعامل الان مع هذا القرار
طبعا الولايات المتحده مستاءه جدا من
مواقف اوبيك
المتشدده لانها خلقت تشدد في الامدادات
وخرقت نقص في السوق وراينا ذلك وانعكس ذلك
على اسعار الوقود الامريكيه في محطات
البنزين والديزل وغيرها والمستهلك
الامريكي طبعا هو الناخب ويعاقب البيت
الابيض في اي انتخابات مقبله لذلك الاداره
الامريكيه تريد مزيد وفره من النفط
وانخفاض في اسعار التجزئه ولهذا سوف تستاء
من هذه الخطوه نذكر ان الرئيس بايدن زار
منطقه الخليج والسعوديه وحاول ان يمارس
الضغوط عليهما لرفع الانتاج ولكنهما رفض
لان الاتفاق الانتاج هو يشمل 23 دوله ولا
تستطيع دوله واحده ان ترفع الانتاج
موافقه البقيه لذلك الان هناك اتفاق شامل
على التخفيض الطوعي بواقع مليون و650 الف
برميل يوميا اعتبارا من بدايه شهر مايوير
المقبل حتى نهايه العام اذا اضفنا ذلك الى
اتفاق الاصلي الذي ينص على تخفيض 2 مليون
برميل يوميا الذي تمت الاتفاق عليه في
الاجتماع رقم 33 خمسه اكتوبر فهذا سيخلق
تشدد كبير في الامدادات وسترتفع الاسعار
اوبك لديها هدف واحد وهو التوازن في
الاسواق وتعني بخلق حاله التوازن الاسواق
هو اسعار مرتفعه اي فوق ال80 دولار
للبرميل والان لان الاسعار انخفضت الى دون
ذلك بحوالي 12% خلال الشهر الماضي لذلك
تاخذ خطوات احترازيه للمحافظه على
مداخيلها وعلى ميزانيتها وتريد اسعارا
مرتفعه في هذه الوقت العصير خاصه
الاقتصاديا شكرا